one of the fastest ways that humanity as
a whole can take a quantum leap and
living more limitlessly is listening to
what they say so here is a simple yet
powerful way to get started right now I
think that really an advanced person
understands that like this nervousness
or anxiety is actually an amazing pain
every one welcome to another episode of
unlocking lily so I believe that this
world would be a better place if we all
just embrace who we truly are evan is
probably an investor in my business and
he's mentoring me to help me build my
coaching and speaking practice and I'm
so incredibly honored to have all of you
guys come with me on my startup journey
I'm always looking for ways to grow and
connect with like hearted people so I
could learn from them and then I'm gonna
take those lessons and share with my
coaching clients as well as the audience
as I speak in front of so today I am
going to learn from keynote speaker
coach and author Daniel Eisenman so I
was introduced to Danielle through Evan
and that's a thing when you vocalize
what is that you need help with people
around you would naturally conjure of
ideas to help you over the past decade
Daniel has hosted these epic retreats in
the most beautiful places in the world
his own daddy video has been shared by
various sources and platforms and is
approximately 100 million views
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah isn't Davina just the sweetest little
baby so here's my interview with Daniel
as we sit down to talk about how we can
all live more limitlessly
in July I want to talk about your
journey a little bit Daniel I mean from
what I've seen from your YouTube channel
I discovered you through your YouTube
channel and I found your coaching your
quantum consoles that's what you call it
so interesting because your approach is
very different your approach is very
much about feeling the person through
and sensing what they're saying it's
never from a place of judgment it's
always from a place of love and care and
I want to find out from you how did your
journey begin were you always like this
or did something happen to causes change
that's a great question I read recently
realized this about myself I have a very
low tolerance for limited thinking or a
limited perceiving and I've realized
that when I honor that front like when I
honor that low tolerance or honor that
frustration just as if you know someone
has zero tolerance to alcohol it's
probably good phenomenon how to drink
too much alcohol for me I being around
limited thinking I just get very
uncomfortable and not the fun okay well
what happens is when I speak up about
like that's true for you if it were the
quantum consultations with a family
member it's with a client whether it's a
retreat it's just a week I'm almost like
I bought chiropractor of consciousness
yesterday because I do believe I am able
like misalignments with someone's
highest self is obvious to me and the
more that I speak up about that I'm
stronger this journey gets it seems like
the more people that want to do a common
constipation the more people don't want
to read my book so it's like by being
with that tension and expressing why I
might be frustrated or tense with
someone that's projecting projection
projecting limitations on to other
people I why by speaking
that's when my journey continuously
begins but honoring that gift that I
have that perception I have for seeing
people's obvious misalignments and then
doing something about it taking action
on that I see it too
as a coach I see that people holding
themselves back and a lot of is
condition limited beliefs though for you
where do you think it comes from where
do you think people's limitations come
from oh I think at first it's like a
natural safety mechanism so I'll use a
metaphor of certain types of fish like
if a fish or a human and this on scuba
goes way deep way deep in the ocean and
they come up too fast without
acclimating properly is extremely
dangerous so I do think something well I
I do like it a deeper belief of mine is
however everything that everyone is
doing is the best for everyone
regardless of what I think of regardless
of what I do and when I do intervene I'm
like hey you know like a lot of times
people speak projected limitations in
the you statement they speak in second
person like so if someone believes you
know you have to do this before you make
this much money I simply wanted the main
things I was giving a clear example when
I hear that type of languaging one of
the main things I ask people is like can
you say that first person and see if you
believe that less or more I would say
98% of people that are willing to do
that realize that anything they speak in
a limiting fashion is actually less true
and they speak about in the first 10 so
it was easier to say you it was easier
to say to you so I do think there's a
natural growth rate that's best for
everyone however I do think culture and
specifically languaging has been
leveraged by people that understand how
to live powerfully and they've taken
advantage of other people that don't
understand that and whether it's
conscious or not I think 98% of the
people in the past speak spells of
limitations over their existence without
being aware they're doing it so one of
my main things is getting people to like
my and including myself I want to be on
this interview
everything always I communicate I want
to be able to accurately report my
experience like I'm journaling my life
out loud like this is my diary welcome
to it and that's how I when I ask other
people live that way I think they get
more true with their highest potential
rather than living up to the standards
of culture and a lot of the standards of
culture are so snuck into language like
I'm not like a girl who also watches but
where in the world did people when the
people start saying you when they met I
how do we all live more limitlessly
that's a good question I think partly
and when I think the Bible I want to I
guess the most distributed book in the
world pretty much starts with describing
how reality was spoken before it was
created so I'm a big believer in breadth
of work or breadth play aka the home
daddy bringing more awareness to my
breath and I love homing I love getting
high on oxygen like I can literally do
that and I can get a freaking I can go
to space basically I can go deep into
inner space by manipulating my breath
and one of the I think in the most
overlooked ways of breath work is our
speaking is manipulating our breath and
two words that are empowering
rather than limiting so I believe in one
of the fastest ways that humanity as a
whole will can take a quantum leap and
living more limitlessly is listening to
what they say list like I listen to what
I say and if I realize what I said was
not the best spell like if I didn't
spell out that like with my words did it
make the best spell for myself and when
I was speaking I will upgrade my spell
that's how I do it and that's how I
imagine and I literally on the interview
when you ask what I mean by them know
thing and everything I do believe like
we're all connected like we are all
cells to the same body or leaves to the
same tree in some way so whenever I'm
meeting someone and if they're not
living up to or what if I have a
bubbling in my heart like oh my gosh
this person just projected the spell
what a wee statement and I don't even
think it's true for
it's definitely not true for me that I
usually follow my heartbeat the
heartbeat that's like the scariest and
exciting at the same time that's when I
personally realize it's time for me to
speak up when I feel that flutter in my
heart so I let my heartbeat guide my way
and then I listen to what I say very
good I think I answer I think that's my
response how can we get humanity a
little more limitlessly uh I said listen
to what I say and let my heart beat got
in my way that's how I do it I wanted to
find out from you with all the folks
that you you worked with what do you do
in that situation with people feel like
people say to you that I'm just not
feeling it I don't know what it is I'm
supposed to listen to okay cool yeah so
I think this would be part of the book
breaking normal I know this universe is
imagining I think you know real clear I
believe and I've asked sister a lot of
people like what's the number one way
that we that you know you're alive right
now and sit in the sense that this is
not like a sleeping dream because have
you ever been in a dream and you thought
it is real yes I have yes how do you
know this is not a treatment I don't
know my mind is blown I don't know all
right so I think one of the best ways in
this inception of this dream life that
we find ourselves and to distinguish our
waking dream versus our sleeping dream
is our sensations in our body so like
right now I can sense the sweat under my
armpit
I can sense like an eighth like a little
from holding Davina on this side I'm
imagining what it is that's an
imagination I don't know why my back is
going this way but I feel a twinge in my
back I can feel the sensations of my
feet touching the ground my butt sitting
on the bed I can feel like my body
temperature rising so basically I found
it super helpful to distinguish between
my notice things versus my imagination
so the sensations like think of a five
sensory experiences that we can have
touching hearing tasting smelling seeing
when I focus on that's my reality that's
my like okay that's the most objective
reality
so I can relate to every human being I
by saying I had heat and my heart rate
is increasing every human couldn't
relate to that if I say I'm nervous I
don't know if me and you experienced
nervousness in the same way I don't know
if me and you experience fear the same
way I would actually say one of the
biggest differences between people like
me let's say to two percent that have
control of most of the amount of money
or the game-changers or the successful
people they basically without ever
sensations in their body the
ninety-eight percent that people think
is sphere or nervousness they get
excited and they have fun with that
that's like the main difference it's
like the person is able to follow that
like that increase in the heart rate
versus the person that runs away from it
and I don't think my true suffering is
experiencing those sensations it's a
it's more closely to avoiding those
sensations so I think by speaking in the
way that I distinguish my sensations
versus my imagination helps me to
realize when I'm coming from a headspace
versus in a reality space because our
imaginations are amazing they can create
new realities especially we continuously
speak about it and focus on it a lot of
the work that I do is I step on stage
and I speak in front of a lot of people
and I used to be I used to call it I'm
feeling so nervous all the times like oh
my god I'm so nervous
and even when you're sitting in the back
room with other speakers you ask each
other it's like so how are things going
and everyone's like oh my god I'm so
nervous and that kind of energy that
it's like that nervousness it goes into
our heads like oh my god I'm not enough
I shouldn't I should have prepared more
what is happening here so recently what
I started doing is really just
connecting what the sensation and not
labeling it anything at all and not
labeling it as if this is a wrong
emotion that I'm feeling I kind of I
expanded my spectrum of my emotions so
and I found it very very helpful because
I used to be the kind of person that I
kind of enjoyed a little bit anxiety
because I felt like it gave me an edge
and then anytime that I was calm I would
feel like oh I'm losing my edge and I
was just labeling emotions like some as
good some as
bad and I realized that I just had to
connect with the sensations and not
label it anything so is that similar to
what you're saying oh so much so a bit
like and I'll go a little farther this
is where I would say like the difference
between tapping our inner spring rather
than like drinking the fluoridated water
approved by the authorities there the
fitting in being normal and being afraid
of awkwardness and anxiety and
nervousness is very normal
it's very built into language and I
think that's changing but breaking
normal and I think that really an
advanced person understands that like
this nervousness or anxiety is actually
an amazing thing it is so profound it's
it's the feeling of tapping a spring is
what in the sense that when there's a
spring tap there's a lot of mud and dirt
and gets out of the way it's like very
dirty it might get dirty process in the
beginning but once the spring is flowing
is flowing and that's where I think the
best speakers in the world like and
probably not imagining you can let me
know I bet some of your best speeches
we're probably when you were almost
blacked out and embracing the
awkwardness or embracing the anxiety
like you said because when I found is
when I embrace these things that a lot
of people have been culturally
conditioned to fear that I actually
become sharper an energy beyond my mind
seems to be partnering with me things I
start saying things I didn't plan and
they were better than I could have
planned I was like what what did I just
say and where's this coming from I think
it's coming from surrendering to the
sensations in my body and actually
increasing them so I would encourage you
myself anyone that's watching this and
they're in that stage where they might
be a little scared being anxious or
avoiding that to start it and next time
you feel anxiety know what that is or
nervousness to find out where that's in
your body and it's most likely going to
be in your someone's throat or their
chest their heart space or their throat
space or their aren't kids or their eyes
might jitter or their finger their hands
might do this or their palms might sweat
and just to increase that as much as
possible and I think what'll happen like
ask your body tonight can you
increase my art cat how much kind of
increase my heart rate how much guy's
sweat in my armpits how much can I'm
tremble
how much can my voice shake when I'm
speaking the day I've found it actually
Subdudes it and a new like a new higher
energy comes in and and then I'm a
steward to that like I'm partnered with
a very pure clean spring water type of
energy I hope you enjoyed the interview
and found it inspirational and at the
same time I know what it just to be a
theory for you I want to make sure that
you applied in your life so that way you
start living more limitlessly so here is
a simple yet powerful way to get started
right now so in the interview Daniel
talks about listen to what you say and
let your heart lead the way what is that
one thing that makes a heart pound
really fast something that is outside of
your comfort zones a little bit scary
but at the same time you know that this
is something that you really want to do
and also understand that your words have
power what you say and how you say it
could either limit you or empower you so
for example and many years ago I wanted
to run these personal development
workshops but I was afraid because it
was outside of my comfort zone I was
really scary for me even though my heart
kept on saying that this is something I
really wanted to do so I would
constantly use words that would limit me
I would say things like I wish I could
but I don't have the time and that's
what kind of kept me down and held me
where I was and eventually and I thought
it was crazy this is what my heart wants
I need to go out there and actually do
it
so I replace those limiting words with
empowering ones instead of saying that I
wish I could but on all the time I
replaced it by saying I am going to run
these fresh
oops and I will make this a priority and
really a month later I ran those
workshops and by running those workshops
eventually led to the opportunity of me
starting a coaching practice and a
speaking practice and all sorts of
opportunities opened up for me because I
stopped using words that limit me and
this is a daily practice for me every
time I feel like there's something that
I really want to do is make my heart
pound fast I always say to myself that I
am gonna make this a priority and it
never steers me the wrong way
but it's a constant practice and really
listening to what you say and letting it
hurt me the way
so for you what is that one thing that
you want to focus on that makes you
heart beat really fast and it's outside
of your comfort zone and now think about
this use words as of you writing a
script to your dream of life and I'm a
social shadow for xenos a No thank you
so much for writing to have really
helped me just come into my last episode
I really appreciate the love finally the
question of the day is what is your
definition of living a life that is
limitless write in the comments below
and I'll sure to join in on the
discussion thank you so much for
watching and more importantly being on
this journey with me
I feel like I'm learning growing and
changing and it gives me in the comfort
and knowing that all of you guys are
there with me every step of the way
so thank you so much again and I'll see
you very very soon
but I would see one was volume you know
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would become like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details